[Music]
they're rising star Ron Adrian who was
at University of Illinois and that's how
I it was that talk in the back of the
room I heard a toilet
Hans liepman who happened to be sitting
in the back of the talk with me Oh
commented about picture physics and I
later found out that it was a term
coined button-button by von Karman who
detested any kind of imaging and viewed
it as pseudoscience and so now I display
it quite proudly with the invention of
CCD cameras and computers we've gone
from picture physics as a as a term of
disdain to one of what a badge of honor
the very heart of all machine vision
applications as I'll talk to you has is
founded in correlation technology and
correlation technology that is it's the
purest form of image processing to some
extent because it's based entirely on
the statistics of the intensity profile
and so everything from video compression
where one's trying to detect the motion
of an object in the plane of view to
pattern recognition where one's trying
to measure sizes of objects in
production and so forth are based on
correlation it's not used very often and
the reason it's not used is it's very
computationally costly and it's slow and
it has some other and because of that
people abandon it and try to search for
other ways to to accomplish the same
process and one of the things we
discovered or I should say I discovered
early on was that in if one's trying to
do local correlation for whatever reason
pattern recognition sizing there's a lot
of redundant information and one need
not resort to
standard techniques which are FFT
spectral correlation to do this
FFT spectral correlation was always
believed to be by far the most
computationally efficient method of
doing this what I stumbled into was the
fact the idea that well there's a lot of
redundant information and the reason you
use that redundant information is to
develop a very high statistical
probability of finding the correct
solution in a local correlation and if
one goes back into information theory
and says well gee the information
content of a single pixel is really the
probability it has to do with the
probability that that pixel or that
intensity exists within some region and
so pixels with low probability have very
high information content and pixels with
high probability have low information
content for instance if you had a black
image with a few white specks the white
specks contain all the information and
the black specks have very little
information so with this idea I said
well why not compress the image and
correlate only on the high probability
component of the image and one can in
fact do that and the trick is how do you
how do you do that and I won't go into
the details here but typical images can
be compressed tremendously in this way a
hundred to one is is not uncommon you
don't recognize what the image looks
like anymore but the image can correlate
quite accurately and what you find out
is that you get about a thousand times
faster than FFT processing if you do
that it's even better than that and the
reason it's better than that is because
it involves integer mathematics that are
very very well tailored to Hardware
right now on a standard PC we can get
about 10,000 vectors a second over a 32
by 32 block and we have a hardware
device that we're actually putting
together right now which we're assuming
a million vectors a second so this is
this is extremely fast by today's
standards of being able to process so
what can you do with it well we we
didn't stop there and the reason we
didn't stop there was we said well
there's got the
one of the problems with correlation is
this it's a statistical process and
therefore there's a certain probability
that you'll find the wrong answer and
that became quite awkward for us so we
developed an yet another technology and
that is if you take two adjacent regions
and you correlate those regions and then
you multiply the correlation table
element by element you're taking a
zeroth-order correlation of a
correlation if you will it's a
second-order correlation what you find
is that all the noise is eliminated if
this is a correlation table and this is
the correlation peak perhaps and you
anything that doesn't correlate with in
both areas then gets eliminated and you
end up with a very very clean signal a
very high signal-to-noise ratio one of
the very interesting things it turns out
is that not only does it give you a very
high signal-to-noise ratio but it has a
very wonderful property in that if these
are two regions I'm going to correlate
and I have some sort of gradient and
displacement occurring between the
regions then the correlation table
yields a gradient that's in the
direction of the gradient or the are
sort of crosswise to the gradient of the
of the direction of the displacement
then if you multiply the correlation
tables together then what happens is
this part doesn't match with this part
and this part doesn't match with this
part and it forces a beautiful Gaussian
that's not Gaussian but I can't draw
Gaussian profile that occurs at exactly
the interface so not only do you have
this advantage where you've boosted your
signal-to-noise ratio it actually goes
as exponential function but you've also
managed to narrow the exact location in
which that correlation occurs so you
know precisely in the image where that
is so now you have a method in which you
can have you have a very very high
probability of being able to locally
correlate and you have a very fast
algorithm what can you do with all this
well I said I was a fluid dynamicists
and that's how I got involved in this
and indeed what you're looking at if it
were a little bit better focused perhaps
is an image taken from a standard
off-the-shelf CCD camera nothing fancy
and these are 60,000 independent
velocity vectors of a swirling flow
undergoing a sudden expansion this is
resolute this is resolved down to the
limits of what we can image and I think
if you look at just one little tiny
section you can see just how fine the
resolution is we can pick up individual
vortices and so forth and we can do this
you know this was a six seconds of
processing to do our new system we're
hoping to do this in real time video
rate with being real-time so so the
technology is is quite exciting with
this kind of accuracy this kind of
resolution one is able to resolve flow
structures in this case to amazing
levels we don't we're not stuck in 2d we
can do it in 3d there's a holographic
cube it was done by Joe Katz it was
processed by us there's over 10 million
vectors in this cube and just to give
you an example of the type of stuff
we're doing so that was I'll get back to
this technology in a second the other
thing we became interested in was a
technology of laser induced fluorescence
which if you look at the information
content within an image laser induced
fluorescence is very hard to be it has
holography and and laser induced
fluorescence or LIF have the highest
information content one can achieve with
a camera and but the problem when you
have when you try to implement this in
real life is that it requires some sort
of light source and that light source
always becomes distorted and so it's
very hard to use as a quantifiable
measure other than to track some
velocity or displacement or such well
the biologists loaned us an interesting
technology for measuring calcium and we
adopted this what we did was we went in
and we put two different dyes into the
oil and the dyes have this interesting
characteristic if you look at here we
were using it
so that's why it says film thickness
although it doesn't it could be it could
be intensity of the laser if you will
and here's the emission and the dye goes
up and then it saturates at some point
either with the intensity or in this
case film thickness it turns out that
one can use the ratio between these two
dyes within the thing to eliminate the
effects or non-uniformity effects of the
imaging properties and in this case
we're using the non linearity part of
the two and if one takes a ratio between
the two this ratio becomes a very strong
function of film thickness and we built
a camera system this is a dual camera
system it's two thermally cool 12-bit C
CDs they're coupled through a what's
called a multi image module which is
made primarily for microscopes we added
a lens on the outside of this and we
have a dichroic mirror on it and we can
separate the two colors between the two
cameras and when you do this just to
give you an example here's a case where
we have some varying film thickness and
you can see the rings that we caused
from our optics of our laser system and
when you take the ratio of this it
completely flattens out the profile and
one is able to measure the relative film
thickness simply from the from this
ratio very accurately one can also well
let me before I get on let me show you
another an application of this one of
the things we did just for fun what I
actually turned out quite interesting we
put a window in the side of a diesel
engine we fired a laser into the diesel
engine as it was running we imaged it
with our camera system and we were
interested in the oil transport through
the ring pack as the engine ran and we
were able to measure oil film
thicknesses accurately down to the half
micron level as the engines running this
is actually a movie
don't have it with me but there's a very
interesting phenomena it became a
best-seller in Detroit I heard it's so
accurate in fact that you can measure
the hook on the ring which is it's about
oh maybe 200 microns or so wide here and
you can detect the oil film thickness in
the 1/2 micron range within that ring we
weren't stuck just measuring oil film
thickness we can do the same thing we
can measure temperature here we have
characteristics of two dyes we have one
that's thermally stable with temperature
and one whose fluorescence drops with
temperature you can mix these and take a
ratio in much the same way we did all
film thickness and if one does this here
we have oil film thickness and we have a
fixed temperature and you can see the
the the gradient due to the film
thickness change but you can also see
the ring laser rings and when you take
the ratio you get a beautiful flat
profile for that shows constant
temperature and in fact we've calibrated
this there are a number of problems in
doing this technology for temperature
not the least of which as nobody has any
information on temperature effects on
dyes so it requires but we've been able
to calibrate this relatively accurately
you see this is from 0 to 200 microns
oil film thickness we're using this in
seals is our primary application looking
at seals and bearings so once we had
this technology we went back to the
correlation technology and said gee why
are we stuck doing it this way why not
take and manufacture small spherical
particles that have two dyes in them and
then presumably we'd be able to measure
the temperature of a fluid at the same
time we can measure the velocity of the
fluid and so these are pearl
polymerization
of Todai spiral methane in rhodamine and
these are about they range
I guess they arrange for three to twenty
microns in diameter and they're made
using an ultrasound process and lo and
behold this is a we imaged it with a
stereo camera pair this is a hot or a
cold fluid entering a hot tank and we
got the three dimensional velocity
profile of the jet and we get the
temperature profile as well just to show
you something a little more dramatic
there's the swirling flow coming in
sudden expansion and the hot fluid is
swirling and coming up into a colder
fluid and you can see how it mixes so we
can image that well this was all well
and good but but fluids was a very
limited application for all this
technology so we got sidetracked and we
came up with another device and that was
why couldn't we use this correlation
technology at such high speeds and do 40
imaging basically 3d imaging and video
rates we came up with a unique device we
have a camera system that has a rotating
aperture within that camera and we
project a speckle pattern onto an object
we have this rotating aperture that
rotates and then as we if you if you
look at the what happens in this system
it's it's a wonderful way to image and
the reason is is if you have the
aperture on one side you get one view of
the image if you have the aperture on
the other side you get another view of
the image if you're at the focal point
of the sorry focal plane of the camera
both images from this aperture position
in this aperture position end up exactly
on the center same spot but if you're
out of focus
they are they there's they are displaced
with by some distance and you can
correlate these two from the images
taken from the two aperture positions
and measure this distance through
correlation
and and one can extract the XYZ
component of the image the beauty of
this system is it's the if you're
looking at a stereoscopic system you
have optical occlusion if you're looking
at a system like this the precision in
the alignment occurs entirely due to the
grinding of the optics which is highly
precise we're using off-the-shelf lenses
now Nikon lenses and we simply attach a
rotating aperture on the back end of
these cameras and so it's a very low
cost I'll show you one that we have a
three dimensional camera that's under a
hundred dollars that I have sitting here
this is a fancier version than the one
I'll show you this is our latest lens
that we're trying to get down to the
diffraction limit of the optics so that
we can get very very high accurate
imaging our little hundred-dollar camera
which I'll show you is capable of doing
this add video rates this is a very
crude cheap camera nothing fancy this
was our very first attempt ever at doing
this and you can image a face we
actually have human faces I didn't want
to put mine up here actually the funny
thing is I'm doing this with a group
that's in Taiwan and they image my face
and the problem was is as they put it on
too prominent
meaning my nose was stuck out too far
and and they had trouble with the
correlation algorithm we had but but
anyway you we can image this you can
rotate it three dimensions the
applications of this range from what
they're interested in and where the
money is I hate to say video games all
the way up to heart surgery and putting
it into scopes being able to go into
probes we can do this extremely low-cost
we could put this on top of a PC we've
got we've done this many times just as a
demonstration model as I'll show you
here but there's any number of
applications I'm interested in this
technology because once you image in
this way things become no long
an image in a computer but an object in
a computer so you treat the world as
objects not images and that's a very
powerful idea you computers are
wonderful things that image processing
but now you have something where
everything in it is a solid model of
something where it can be rotated and
manipulated transformed so forth
let me cause I'm running out of time I
don't want to run out over and get you
back on schedule
I don't know whether this is gonna work
or not I have a I have this was the
camera that took that image it's with
lens it's a hundred dollars it's a very
cheap device and all we did was take
this you can see it's a very small
aperture too so it's not particularly
accurate a good aperture lens we're now
using F 1.4 85 millimeter lenses which
have far better accuracy but so this
tiny little lens in the middle of it
we've stuck an off-axis iris and we've
just connected it so that we can rotate
it and if I can set it down here perhaps
I can image something that one can look
at and see how it displaces focus in I
can rotate it but if I rotate the
aperture you see how the image is
shifting it shifts in a circular pattern
and you notice you notice the background
is shifting the opposite direction I
don't know whether you can see it
through my shaking
not sure whether that was apparent but
the what's nice about this technology is
it's 30 Hertz so we can image and get 3d
but if you sit there it the aperture is
rotating so it's taking different
information each time it takes an image
and so as you set it there the accuracy
of your image becomes greater and
greater than greater so it just sort of
fades in you get you get a fairly good
image with just two and then you get
three four five six images and the
accuracy improves with each image and
it's almost goes down to whatever the
distortion of your optics are and your
ability to calibrate out that Distortion
George will show a really fascinating
device where he's eliminated a limb
our objective here is to is to develop a
device that's robust fast low-cost
camera for the masses anyway I'll take
any questions if I still have a few
minutes
[Applause]
no market but I'll sell you know the the
company they're actually the group I'm
working with want to sell it currently
it's interesting they got cheap on us
and they only bought these the patent
rights to it for Taiwan and we still MIT
still holds the rights to to the United
States and Europe and Japan and which is
interesting because all the they paid
for the development of it and all the
users are in the are outside their realm
so yeah we're in a good shape on this
one
the result it depends greatly on the on
your optical setup is really what an
amount to the diffraction limit is the Z
direction is the diffraction limit in
the same as the XY so you're about 10
microns that's T that's if you push the
technology to the extreme in a in a
practical system like we're talking
about here with a really low cost image
and camera you know we're near
diffraction limited of course R for the
size of a head our Z Direction is the
same as the XY so if you have 512 pixels
across the face you have essentially
five pill pixels in the depth as well
equivalent to yeah this camera scans at
30 years how fast is the aperture moving
the aperture moves roughly 90 degrees
every every image so it rotates we don't
worry about blurring because it
correlates out it's a board in the same
direction so we just take the blurring
and live with it we we have plans for a
very high speed application where we
take a burst of data and there we use
LCD high-speed apertures and instead of
rotating well we just fix them in two
spots and just go click click click
click click click and hopefully we can
get high-speed motion that way
[Applause]
information system really can't be
polite I mean also it's amazing that the
kinds of applications suggest once you
get going down let's grow join external
speaker is a forms to eat corpses
professor of mechanical engineering the
professor of bioengineering at the large
division at MIT and he's going to talk
to us
I came biomedics
the opportunity to speak to you today
was something that I really grabbed onto
because I think it's an opportunity to
really pay tribute to an investment that
Nam su made in the department a number
of years ago it was a real risk when he
went out and encouraged everybody to get
involved in the information technology
and in particular invested in a lot of
young faculty coming into the department
who had information technology as one of
their key tools and in my opinion that
investment has paid off marvelously and
I think it's hard now looking backwards
to realize what a risk it was at the
time so this is the first opportunity
I've had to really I pay tribute to what
I think is one of the outstanding
decisions in the department over the
last 20 years to me information
technology is absolutely essential to
deal with the enormous amount of data
that we have streaming in from every
different corner of our technological
universe and what I'd like to do today
is to talk to you a little bit about
bioinformatics and some of the work
we've been doing to handle all of the
biological and medical information I'm
going to go through just a couple of
quick slides to tell you a little
background this is the
this is my my team of students gone Dow
is my lead information architect and Pat
McCormick was previously Pat is now out
with a startup in Silicon Valley called
tell me which will be going public in
about six months or last so you should
watch for that he was the seventh
employee out there and I have already
been dunning him about contributions to
the Institute when that happens he was
involved in the 50k competition at MIT
as in gone Dale in fact his team won the
50k competition at MIT this past year
and in in as a comment to some of the
ideas that alex d'arbeloff was talking
about at lunch I think that that's a
very innovative program where in fact
the students in order to to compete have
to go out to the marketplace and
understand the needs of the marketplace
and formulate solutions because the
prize is they get fifty thousand dollars
from a series of judges who come out of
the venture capital community and in
fact they have an opportunity and an
encouragement from that community to go
out and commercialize but in the ideas
they come up with this whole 50k
competition has been is now being
replicated by many many other
universities and I think it's a
marvelous incentive for students to go
out and in fact make that connection
between market need and and technology
I'll just skip a couple of slides here
the international consortium for medical
imaging technology is something we
started in 1990 and it has been one of
the things that has sponsored a lot of
the research I want to talk about today
I'd like to go through with you about
what the needs are in the bioengineering
and in particular in the large datasets
that you get in medicine and biology
describe those information objects talk
about the technology that we can use to
organize that information in query it
talked about several solutions that are
possible and then just quickly run
through a series of projects that we're
working on at the present time now why
do we need information technology well
further first of all the amount of data
that is coming out of the medical and
biological communities is just enormous
no longer do you take a whole week to do
a single experiment with a gene chip you
can do 10,000 experiments in one
afternoon so the the stakes have just
changed by orders of magnitude and our
ability to deal with all of that
information and rational way as not
second thing is that the information you
need to make an intelligent decision for
example in trying to do rational drug
design requires that you pull together
pieces from many different databases
many different models different
experiences and in order to do that you
need in architecture that will support
that kind of query finally you can't do
these systems one-off and expect them to
be robust and secure and complete
they're going to break the minute
in an academic setting the minute the
graduate student leaves it will never
get rebuilt in an industrial setting the
minute that the person that built it
gets pirated it away the the company
struggles in patches for the next five
years until somebody redesigns a new
system you can't afford to do that what
you really need is an architecture that
will survive just to give you some some
examples an EM our image of 256 by 256
by 2 bytes per pixel by 40 pictures
already slices in about 5 megabytes if
your medical record contains a thousand
pages 400 words per page and 10 bytes
per word you've got 4 megabytes so 1mr
image is basically worth all the all the
written information about you in the
medical record in terms of space terms
of the ability to query and so forth to
give you an example Beth Israel Hospital
has saved for the last 16 years all of
the patient encounters of all the
patients that have gone through in terms
of the textual information that's been
involved with it that total which a few
years ago looked huge is 18 gigabytes
that's smaller than the disk drive that
was just installed in my in the computer
in my lab actually yesterday so these
things are changing very rapidly now let
me tell you why this is a multimedia
problem and here's a simple example out
of Neil Pappalardo area this is an x-ray
this is just a schematic of it and here
are the annotations about that x-ray
that we're put in the air by by an
expert and this is all useful
information this is the x-ray somebody
else can pick up the two but those two
pieces of information are disconnected
and it's a very simple matter to try to
key that textual information to the
image itself
this increases the information content
it allows you to distribute it and use
that information in a much more open and
system so this is just a very simple
example you can get much more
complicated when the image analysis
becomes more difficult so just to
summarize we've got in the whole bio
engineering and medical community we
have clinical information hospital
records that may be important we have
engineering data on materials we have
engineering models of the cardiovascular
system we have chemical models
biochemical models of reaction rates and
so forth and we have various
experimental results where we've gone
out into the laboratory for Regine ships
and otherwise to get data there is also
the entire biological sphere which
includes as I mentioned the gene chip
arrays and the human genome database
which is now being completed there's
just an enormous variety of data here
and our challenge that we've been
looking at is how to connect all these
different ones let me give you another
example that is a case that we're
working on locally with Brigham and
Women's Hospital this is a drug
discovery and drug testing protocol
where we have a hundred patients each
patient gets measured twenty times all
of these patients have multiple
sclerosis and we're trying to look to
see how the lesions that you can pick up
with appropriate image analysis change
over function of time the data amounts
very rapidly for this
tens of gigabytes we also have an
equivalent amount of information after
the images have been analyzed and what
we're trying to pick out from that is in
fact whether the frequency of the
lesions and the size of the lesions and
so forth will change with the use of one
drug or another and then to correlate
that with information in a genetic
database you know I have a little movie
here and you have to watch very closely
down in this lower right hand corner
because unfortunately it goes very fast
I've not figured out a way to slow down
my computer normally you like a fast
computer but in this case it's too fast
so let's see if we can what you were
looking at and that was in fact 20
different time points for a single
patient all of the images re registered
exactly by use of image analysis
techniques and then each time point took
about 10 hours on a large Sun machine to
do the segmentation to get the
individual lesions nonetheless that's
the kind of data that are going to be
used to effectively do drug trials and
drug discovery so the how are we going
to go about developing common component
software for this environment and
bringing these different information
pieces together well I have three things
that I would propose one is to use open
software tools to the extent that you
can things that will operate on multiple
platforms the second thing is to try to
get international standards and there
are some that are in existence and more
coming and finally to try to take the
best view you can of leading technology
and and see where you expect the field
to be in five years so that you don't
designed to a standard that's either
going to go away or or become less
important well you've got a lot of
choices today for the kind of tying
together of these information
environments and I've just given you
some eye candy here to try to suggest
what all of those various choices are
I'm sure you've heard of Java I'm hurt
sure you've heard of XML which is an
extension of the HTML language that was
used in all of the browser technology
and and so forth korva means common
object request broker architecture DICOM
is a medical imaging standard hl7 is a
medical informatics standard tcp/ip is
the connection protocols that have been
used since the mid 80s all of these
things are available and you have
various proponents of them and the
question is how do you architect
something that uses these in an
intelligent way well they're just just
briefly there are three classes of
software you have to develop one is user
access software this is really the
client part of it you need databases for
the storage systems and finally the
third piece is the intermediate piece
which is the exchange software and
that's the one I want to emphasize here
here all the clients up here you're
trying to run various models you're
trying to do analyses of data you're
querying about which patients are in
trouble and so forth down here you have
all sorts of different databases and and
and varied information and how do you
put together the software layer that
pulls all that together well first thing
you want to do is you want to start with
object-oriented technology and I simply
say that
it used to be you could just put things
in a in a file system and name the file
and remember where it was but there's
too much data now you can't do that you
can't exchange it ordinary relational
databases can't deal with the multimedia
object-oriented databases have a real
problem because there are no good
standards for those the object
relational is pretty good but it's not
absolutely necessary to this process but
the one thing you do get if you use an
object-oriented system is that all of
this multimedia stuff is transparent you
can describe up here in an
object-oriented program exactly what's
in the database so the programming
paradigms become very simple if you
don't use an object relational system
then you get or an object-oriented
system then you get into a real problem
that you have to make all sorts of
compromises in the relational system in
order to get this object-oriented view
from the outside one of the things we
did is an example was to take the DICOM
medical imaging standard which is an
international standard and make a
completely object relational database
out of it you can't read all of the
details here but it was incredibly
successful at allowing you to go in and
query the image on its characteristics
in a very enlightened way in such that
the image itself as well as all of the
derived information was all available
within the database with a common in
query format here's another example we
have more than just databases we have
models here's the cardiovascular model
of Roger cam in our department has
developed this and what we're doing now
is to put this on the web so that the
model itself can query
database automatically for the
information it needs a an outside user
on the web can come in and set these
various parameters and the model will
then run and produce information about
what the various pressures are and the
flows are around the cardiovascular
system this will be very nice for
teaching but you can imagine that these
kinds of models are going to get more
and more important for playing what if
games in the clinical environment and
for drug discovery now the the key
technologies here reside in this
interface here's the typical client
here's a database there's a request goes
to the database results come back
but the database in fact would be fairly
complex it could be a model which goes
to another database right so there's a
cascading effect that happens over here
and the client doesn't necessarily need
to know anything about that all the
client needs to know is what kind of
request has to be put back and how to
interpret what comes the other way so
we've developed a number of concepts to
deal with that one of the ones that's
been very successful is to use something
called a class mapper to produce an
object-oriented view of the database
independent of whether the database is
object oriented or not then what we do
is we wrap that in what's called an XML
wrapper we then send that through a
common object request broker environment
that picks up the transport protocols
exchanges the XML with the client the
client then knows how to unwrap the XML
and to display the results so in a
nutshell that's what we do this is just
a another way to look at it here's the
user up here putting input in and
getting display back the request is
interpreted you can look on this as the
transport layer here's now the database
this is the class mapper here that
the interface to the database I have an
example that I can show somebody later I
guess I'm out of time right four more
minutes all right okay well anybody
that's interested in how one applies
this to the new gene chips that are
coming out from Affymetrix and so forth
I'll be happy to talk to you about it
later
just qualitatively what we have here is
a basic chip schema that has been
published by this genetic analysis
technology consortium which is basically
a foe metrics and a couple of their
friends this is very probe centric in
the sense that it just defines what's on
the chip but there's no way to connect
that with something like the human
genome database for example so and
furthermore you don't know where that
ship came from or what the conditions
were under which it was taken
what what kind of subject information
it's not connected right so the next
thing you have to do is you have to add
all the information about how the sample
was prepared and what the sample
represents so that's part of your
database as well then the next thing you
have to do is you have to connect that
with the public gene databases so that
you can now begin to make sense out at
the entire system and this is an ongoing
project that we have right now that I
think is very exciting because we
probably unless we stumble we're
probably be the first people to actually
be able to connect the new human genome
databases with the Afra metrics chips in
a way that you can go in and query at a
very high level like give me give me all
of the patients who have the following
genetic profile and see if you can match
the following genes or here are six
genes
these various people I want you to take
those six jeans two at a time and I want
you to find the correlation between
those two genes for the following people
and then correlate that against the
following diseases that they may have I
mean these are the kind of high level
things you want to do at an
object-oriented environment but you
can't do that unless all of the
machinery works appropriately underneath
it
well I've mentioned most of the systems
that we've been working on except the
integrated health care since 1990 we've
been working on some integrated patient
record systems they've been pretty well
adopted now in the UK and they provide
the clinical physician with a very good
multimedia environment so I just like to
close by saying that what we're trying
to do is to get better diagnosis and
therapy through technology thank you
very much yes
what we have done in most of our work is
to use the informants object relational
database which is quite similar to the
db2 that that iBM has the the other big
one is is the Informix database which is
not as developed but we just simply use
this class mapper idea to handle that
there is also an issue about object
oriented queries which you can solve
with SQL three but SQL three is still in
the standards development phase and you
have to make a few compromises there but
those have not been nearly as difficult
as somebody with an equal negative
problem around a computer scientist so
my question is that there is some kind
of admitting somebody can order you can
evolve or somebody who could put the
science they do with this kind of
project by training black backgrounds
like third parties excluding here
I got into this through the backdoor by
doing a lot of image analysis and
getting involved using optics with lots
of lots of experiments in the laboratory
you know if we're really successful at
this this Doug and and George and lots
of others are we're just going to be
generating data that are just coming out
of our ears what do you do with it and
all of a sudden it was very obvious to
me that this was a wonderful challenge
and I knew the marketplace as Alex said
I knew the marketplace that's that that
was my big unfair advantage over anybody
in computer science so then it just
[Music]
exactly two questions brought up you
know do you have the course we know the
technology the development
it will actually I'd like to second or
third what what you're saying that it's
a common around that the many of us
taking against like photo saying when we
do optics and imaging to try to develop
this technology very common question is
what you do with the data so some of us
take the computer science approach for
some others they approach is more
cognitive so we ask the question well
how does the brain do this in car so you
know then again it doesn't matter which
department you belong right as long as
we're having fun with it
it's okay okay discovered he hasn't even
longer titled of mine I lied his the
Esther and Harold Edgerton career
development assistant professor
[Music]
thank you come here is this sounds like
a really exciting conference and the
actuary the previous speaker actually
set up what my talk is going to be very
well when step was asked first asked me
to give a talk in the ID conference I
say well mostly finger myself as the
hardware builder so I was saying well
what am I doing with information
technology then I start going back to
look at what I do in my lab and start
thinking well actually almost all I do
everything that I do have some
information technology content in there
and some of them actually quite exciting
so this is a little bit of the work that
what I am doing that I'm going to tell
you about here and so I looked at it
biological systems are probably some of
the most complex systems as Fox has so
you for for a while traditional biology
and medicine is extremely descriptive if
you look at an x-ray let's say radiology
sly and what a good doctor can extract
whether useful information whereas are
not a so good doctor populate on extract
later you saw information but you
wouldn't know and who is good and who is
bad and today with the information
technology that we have and is quickly
advancing we are at a position where we
can really start to untangle and
quantify the complex matrix of
information that one could get in a
biological system in particularly
biological imaging which I think I will
focus on and in some way the
quantification of biological system
creatures in particular including
ourselves is critical to control how
they function and which of course
related to medical treatment as well as
possibility of developing new products
today my talk is going to be in three
parts
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what the advances in information
technology has allowed me to do today
which I don't think is able to do about
maybe five years ago in terms of how to
use information technology to impact
biologic somewhat higher biological
imaging applications
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
how how does some type of biomedical
imaging problem pushes the frontier of
algorithm development in terms of how to
process information such that you can
extract useful information from a really
complex biological data finally I'm
going back one step and say well as the
information technology developed we are
able to do new things and we are
developing new algorithms but with new
instrument development we are actually
pushed generating more and more data and
actually we are generally getting data
in a public exponential rate today and
which of course would give you further
demand in the events of information
technology
let me I'm going to focus on the first
problem
what does information technology has
allow us to do today that we cannot do
before one of the essential question in
terms of cancer biology as well as the
treatment of cancer is how this mutation
occur what are the rare mutations
mutation being the one of the main cause
of carcinogenesis the initiation of
cancer in the body can you quantify the
rate of mutations for a normal person as
well as when a person is exposed to
various toxins so the question is can
one develop a system such that you can
look at one type of recombination which
we are interested in which is called one
time mutation which is called a
recombination that we are interested in
this is some work that we are doing in
collaboration with Bevan Engel work in
bioengineering and Health Science
Division so how do you quantify mutation
as it turns out there are wonderful
things in biology that you can actually
put a gene in almost any normal organism
that you can manipulate such as mice to
make them grow green this is a protein
called GFP if you put the protein in you
can make a mouse go green but
can also okay now you might ask why do
you want to make things go green now of
course it makes a extremely cool picture
number one and now the reason is now if
you want to make measure mutation rate
you can put in a defective copy of the
gene into the animal but when there is a
mutation the defective copy would come
by with a second copy that is complete
when that happens a cell goes green so
now you can have a fluorescent marker in
the animal that you can watch how many
cell go green where they go green if
they go green let's say it's a mutation
does this particular Kong expand does it
become a big tissue that is green which
is some way is kikuno expansion and it's
very important for cancer so there are a
couple things that you have to do number
one is you need a genetic engineer that
can make the mouse for you number two is
you need some technology such that you
can look into tissue to count the green
cells and look at the distribution of
the green cells relative to the rest of
the tissues and the animal so the
technology that I have a way about in my
lab is so called two-photon microscopy
I'm not going to go into the detail here
um the only thing I'm going to say is
using a red light if you shoot at the
right the red light in the right way you
can generate a fluorescence at a
three-dimensional localized spot on the
order of 1 micron on each side so now
you have a teeny beacon of light that
you can put into the mouse or into a
person and map out the fluorescence if
you can do that then you can look
through the tissue of a mouse and can
the number of green cells so could use
this is a fourth experiment we haven't
really done it yet
so the idea is we would have a mouse
hopefully not the whole mouse goes green
because mutation wait don't go dose it's
not that high you can in take the skin
of the mice out lay it flat you might
have to cure it but that's ok you would
now image individual volumes in the skin
of the mouse and in 3d you can go into
individual
so layers and look for green cells now
if you think about this process it
doesn't sound so difficult but it is
actually a very difficult thing to get
in updater spontaneous mutation rate
that's mutation rate or one gene in any
of given our given cell it's on the
order of one part in ten to the fifth to
one part in 10 to the six it doesn't
happen so often and it's a good thing
otherwise we are in trouble so if you do
a quick calculation given the image I
just show you how many images you need
to get enough statistic to say something
useful you need about ten hundred
thousand to the images about two
thousand 3d image stacks and creatures
on the order about website that's not a
t10 gigabyte of data it's not ten
terabyte of data but but on the other
hand if you do a thousand experiments
you'll get two terabyte but on the other
hand 10 gigabyte of data doing a hundred
experiment on the order of couple months
is not entirely unreasonable one of the
thing that I say is the advance in
instrumentation is very great we expect
you to take all these images within few
hours okay so we can be richer out the
data and if there are enough specimen
available we have a huge forward data
and of course what are the problem the
problem is 4.0 very well if you have
such tremendous amount data where are
you going to look if you are looking for
a needle in a haystack let's say even if
you find the green cell if you want to
go back to it you are not going to go
for a file structure and finder in fact
the field file that has the useful
information so it one of the main
problem that we have today is how do we
have high-speed storage retrieval and
analysis of this sort of information at
the rate that this data is generated now
we can I think today's technology can
handle it and that's why we are
embarking on this study we are now
creating the mouse and doing the 3d
imaging of the mouse when we are able to
achieve that we will have a lot of
information and we can analyze that at
the same time we also recognize that
today the end
article two for 3d imaging and 3d data
analysis is very lacking so we are
working with Forbes of course and also
Peter Sagar working on a very parallel
effort in developing a software platform
a software architecture based on cover
that would allow us to focus on
exchanging 3d data's looking at
acquisition or nyan or flight data
analysis models as well as storage and
retrieval so let me move on to a second
item that I think is also very important
is today why we are our instrumentation
and biological system the data is
extremely complex why we want to be able
to analyze them storage to store them
and you in the end retrieve them to end
for analysis when actually if we take a
look at the algorithm that we have for
some update the data analysis they are
not quite advanced enough for some for
what some of what we want to do and one
of the problem that we have going back
to the example of cancer is pathology
the standard method of pathology is look
at the tissue tissues don't look right
take out tissue slice of tissue send to
the microscope pathologist look at it a
good pathologist pick out the cancer
which is all very good but on the other
hand if one can do that non invasively
it would be great so one of the idea
that we have in our lab is if we have to
function on microscopy that we can look
into tissue one could in principle do
optical biopsy so now and we could do
that this is a quick movie of a 3d
images of the skin of a mouse we just
well actually killed a mouse because it
moved a little bit too much we kill the
mouse we punchers piece of tissue from
the skin put it on the microscope and we
image it and we can look at individual
layers from the from the mouse skin and
then we can look at what what can you
see as you can see on the surface of the
skin
you see individual hexagons
shape things days those are that sells
on our skin that's ready to fall off and
then because we have a free dimensional
data cure we rotate around for the fun
of it and then it will come back the
other side and the color that you see a
false color which means that they are
representing intense the only red color
means it is more intense so you slice it
through you can see individual dead
cells and you can see living cells
underneath it and when you go a little
bit people you can actually see the
collagen elastin fibers that form the
structural support for your for your
skin and when you go a little bit deeper
you can actually see the cartridge
that's a pasta year so this is already
well you can certainly extract
structural information from a lot of
biological specimen that's quite
exciting but on the other hand one thing
that's very important is as a stock has
mention for fluorescence has tremendous
additional dimensions doug has mentioned
that fluorescence spectroscopy has allow
him to measure temperature has allow him
to measure and the properties of a
particular for a system that he have
been looking at in my case one of the
thing that's very interesting is if you
are looking at different colors at the
same layer of the skin you are going to
see different things why is that because
at each individual pixel that we are
looking at it has many different
biochemical components and purity to we
solve the different biomechanical
component give you additional
information for the diagnosis of cancer
and automatically rotations so we are
now include working in collaboration we
have talked to Peter Kaplan and dr.
hands awakes in Unilever corporation
looking at methods of combining both
image data as well as spectroscopy data
and such that you can at each individual
pixel not only found a structure but
identify individual spectral components
that's associated with it
in some way curve resolution the ability
to resolve individual structural
components and spectral components of a
spectrum have been around for a while
but today we finally have images that
combine both high-resolution structural
information with high resolution
spectral information now we can think
about combining image based analysis
methods such as segmentation to fit it
in as a constraint to resolve individual
struct spectral components in individual
pixels of our images this is some of our
beginning work we have not used that the
image information yet but we have been
able to a different F of the skin
resource seven structural components
corresponding to different wailings in
the in the tissue and for example at the
middle of the tissue we can see this
particular layer this is all the pixel
with this matram and they are
corresponding to the college melanin
that's sitting at the middle of the
tissue that you can see similarly you
can go up to this tissue surface that
this spectrum has most of the component
close to the surface and you can see
individual cells on the surface some of
the fingers were interesting if you are
going into the collagen elastin fibers
that fit within the dermis you can
actually based on the special difference
resolve different components of the
fiber so which is consistent with what
people think there are many different
biochemical with different collagen and
elastin structures that's in the skin so
new biological problem Cruise's the need
for new analytical algorithms but
another thing that's very important is
bio instrumentation and moving forward
in a very great rate in a way of
acquiring data that's tremendously
impressive that one would think about
that you are generating more and more
data faster and faster and you
higher capacity to handle those problems
so one of the thing that Forbes has
mentioned a lot is gene chip technology
the ability to now sampling on the other
10 to the 3 to 10 to the 4 different
genes from a bunch of cell at the same
time it's a great advance in in
understanding the genetic changes in
humans and other organisms but today in
many ways this is almost a post genome
era we are really at a pond where the
gene the genes are most people of humans
are would be sequencing within a year so
we know every single gene that is around
the question is is it possible to now
thinking about mapping individual genes
from individual pieces of tissues and
also mapping that in each individual
cells question is can we do a gene map
gene expression map at individual cells
well creatures a major challenge current
gene chip takes about 10 to the 5th to
10 to the 7 cells to take a run which is
quite a bit of selves if you are
thinking about looking at casino Genesis
type problem so what are the major
limitation that you need so many cells
one of the limitation is really chemical
kinetics chemical kinetics require you
have certain concentrations of the
reactants which are the extracts of the
cells to be present so that you can bind
to the gene ship and of course the total
among a material that you need to put in
is proportional to the volume of the
chip and the volume of the chip is
number but limited by technology such as
fabrication imaging and fluid handling
so in collaboration we have a dr. Reagan
and dr. Bennion in Whitehead Institute
we have been looking at different method
of trying to actually handle the problem
of reducing the cells needed to
sequences to sequence to find the
expression of individual Cheung
a tissue our fuel cells how much time do
I have five minutes five minutes okay so
one of the technique that we have
developed in our lab is single wave
total internal reflection microscopy we
are thinking about using it to do
paddling I'm not going to go into the
detail of the technology but the
technology is a method that allows you
to do imaging at very high resolution
normal optical system like most of the
optical lithography method are limited
by the resolution of light and typical
optical resolution limit for about 500
nanometer light is on the order of 100
120 nanometer which is the blue curve
however if you use a new technology that
we have been developed
we have some that we can image at the
red curve which is about 80 nanometer
and we think that we can push this
technology down to about 50 now one of
the thing the thing about is today the
chips has individual elements on the
other 20 to 100 microns if we can
actually push this element down to the
resolution that's close to the
resolution limit of this technology we
would have may be able to king by a
factor of a million in terms of volume
reduction even if we can't do it we can
do a million we can almost do single
cell well even if we don't do a million
if we can do ten to the thousand to ten
to the four we can still start thinking
about doing gene expression profiling on
the order about hundred cells and so
this is really a conceptual slide if we
have the mice if we can now at the
beginning of the talk and telling you we
now have a method to look at the change
of one gene over the whole mice question
is can we in about 10 years develop
method such that instead of monitoring a
single gene at every spot of the animal
can we actually monitor 10 to the 4 gene
at every single spot of the animal and
so if we can do that information that
would be generated from this sort of
experiment
would be tremendously wast and and I
[Applause]
[Music]
would say you have I guess ideally over
Sony's new internet you're a picture of
images of million I certainly see some
of that it's going to happen as I was
saying that if we are looking at the
whole Mouse just looking at Chris cells
are turning green if you are imaging the
amount of data that we are imaging on
the order of 20 caballo data just to
find the right frame that you have a
mutation to occur it's a problem and I
think basically the technology that Fox
is developing and other peoples are
looking at licenese Internet technology
you have to have a storage medium that
in January would be far away so how to
retrieve the data and all that is really
some of sunny and false work is critical
for some of these 1000 this type
diagnosis and si to work
so actually it means the one thing that
strikes me is kind of interesting about
this while such as setting up as it may
have been this morning talked about how
by pushing the limits of manufacturing
capability you can make the chips you
know details on chip smaller and smaller
that in turn is drive exchange
increasing in capacity for information
processing and memory without that it
would not be possible to deal with all
the information that you guys are
getting from pushing the limits of doing
the imaging down to smaller and smaller
scales I mean it's it's a funny
symbiosis between these that like you
can increase your ability to handle
visual information at exactly the same
time you could have be literally
destroyed because you're developing the
same techniques because in factories
technically some of both of these
advances come by developing the optical
techniques that allow you to do some
diffraction limit or at the fraction of
limited imaging the imaging allows you
to create the chips the imaging allows
you to get the data and the chips allow
you to store on process today that's a
very interesting thing is one of the
thing that is optical talent is really
advancing in tremendous way I mean for
optical microscopy and imaging has a
resolution on the order about 300
nanometer or 200 nanometer for the last
pretty much 300 years and they are very
little advanced in this area people go
to a new sort of wavelength which a
course allows you to go shorter but
there are limitations in terms of light
sources but one thing that is
tremendously interesting is right now
there are a number of groups that is
really developing some really high
resolution imaging technology and those
technology can be turned it for
fabrication and there are potential of
doing objects on the other pans to 20 to
50 nanometer scale which i think is very
exciting
who also has a title longer than me I
know he's assessable either green career
development associate mechanical
engineering and if you'll be talking to
us about the auto ID Center this does
not have to do so far as I know with
bioinformatics however Ian Hunter who is
going to talk at this time slot at his
daughter's birthday party at this time
so such a clan they need to switch
however it does as you'll see it's
closely related before the study see was
talking about
you know Sonny your uncle did Sonny's in
Tennessee to put it on for president now
what I'm going to talk about today is
the Auto ID center it's a new brand new
center which is now a part of the Diablo
flab we thank Harry asada for inviting
us to him lab and thank Alex Diablo if
he's still there for setting up the lap
yeah the Auto ID Center is in a sense a
project which brings together the
internet and the physical world
now data has always existed in kind of
an island of its own and what we're
trying to do is put the internet bring
them to the last foot you know we talk
about the last mile problem in the
internet the last ten miles we talked
about the last foot problem where
eventually we hope that the Internet can
in a sense reach every physical object
what I will do today is tell you about
our Center it was established on October
1 1999 and tell you what our vision is
this research is done in conjunction
with sunny sue and David Brock and I'll
be presenting them in my work if you
look at the robotics revolution which
never happened in a sense it was the
perception revolution robotics succeeded
but the perception problem is always
being a kind of a bottleneck in using
robots to their fullest extent the
reason is that perception is a very
difficult problem and the way we
perceive in robotics is we try and
recreate the object or recognize the
object through a very slender a very
slender understanding of perception
for example image processing you take an
image you do image a digital image
processing and then you say well that
looks like a glass and let's maybe I'll
try and pick it up now now the problem
with that is it's unreliable its
capability is limited and it's brutal
the question you might ask is that most
artificial objects are made by someone
and all the information about these
artificial objects is already known so
why try and recognize that won't it be
wonderful if we had a sixth sense which
we could quickly refer to as identity
and if you could somehow sense this
identity then all the information is
available to us that is kind of the crux
of the problem we're we're seeking to
attack I'll make this a very quick
presentation because we should we would
like to catch up with our schedule the
bottom line is that automatic
identification refers to the placement
of an ID on a physical object if a man
or a woman made the object then surely
you can put an ID on it and if you can
put an ID and if you can read the ID you
know everything you need to know because
a man or a woman made the object and all
the information is stored somewhere
that's the key point
now this ID concept
not new in 1972 a bunch of gross grocery
grocers come from the committee called
Uniform Code Council and they invented
something called the barcode and they
came to MIT and they said can you look
at this and tell us how long window it
will have will to survive the logical
scanning be available for us and it
might he told them 25 years we can give
you a 25 year window we're gonna show
you that was June of last year okay so
for 25 years barcodes have survived and
have revolutionized the retail industry
okay today five billion barcodes are
scanned every day however despite the
promise barcodes didn't deliver on
certain deliverables that were promised
at that point the first is that barcodes
an on line of sight so although we
thought that barcodes are automating
everything in fact they didn't a barcode
is printed by a company but it's only
used once in its lifetime and that once
is at the checkout okay the problem is
that barcode is not is non line of sight
and it cannot be read automatically it's
a manual process won't it be wonderful
if you could get around that and if we
could then the opportunities are really
quite amazing and that's what we are
talking about the auto ID Center
wouldn't it be wonderful if you had an
online site ID okay where you could put
the ID and somehow sense it if you could
do that all you could do is put the ID
on the object and put all the
information about the object somewhere
else and by coincidence the internet
exists today so you can access all that
information with very little overhead
you couldn't do that 25 years ago but
you can do that now okay that's the key
now others have thought about this idea
and people have been Dukas of doing
research in this for example I know in
the robotics world several members of
the Diablo of lab have said you know
would it be great if we had an invisible
ink and that's basically what we're
trying to do there is a new chip that is
becoming available today it is called
electromagnetic guide electromagnetic
identification techniques that's the
general term for it and I have here the
business card of one of the vendors off
of the ship this gentleman is from
Motorola on the back of it you will see
an ID chip okay I'm going to pass this
around but we very much appreciate it if
you handed it back to us at the end
thanks
the chip consists of a piece of silicon
with two antennae okay and it is passive
the way it is passive is it has a little
resonator resonates with the ambient
field radio waves
okay picks up energy charges up a
capacitor and then powers the chip which
sends a chip back to the reader so it's
completely passive today we have one
trillion bits and it's growing 128 bits
by the way is enough to number every
atom on the surface of the earth
individually okay so there's no shortage
of IDs we can assign the the price today
is about 20 25 cents and remember we
haven't had bulk yet if you if you can
start making bulk make manufacturing
these in bulk we are thinking that the
price may dropped about 5 cents and one
of our sponsors has informed us that at
five cents they'd be willing to put it
on consumer items that you can buy in a
grocery store ok and finally the range
we get out of these are a few you know a
few feet two feet one foot that
particular tag are we have read it
that's a 4 feet okay that's the basic
technology EMI D tags are manufactured
by a number of companies today Texas
Instruments Philips Motorola Arizona
microchip they're mostly used in
security cards so you can identify
yourself when you enter a room for
example and but there's been some very
interesting research at MIT Neil
Gershenfeld at the Media Lab and others
including our groups and we are being to
find that these chips can now move
beyond these very niche applications of
security and entrance to a very vigorous
application in physical objects and
identification of physical objects the
applications we are being to realize are
really very exciting one of the key
applications is the supply chain you
know we talked about bits and bytes but
eventually human history has been shaped
by the supply chain
I mean wars have been fought in the
supply chain in America is discovered
because of the quest for India for the
supply chain of spice the Silk Route the
supply chain is in a sense the most
important stream that runs through our
lives and barcodes and now
radiofrequency tags have the potential
of changing the way the supply chain is
automated today we talk about the
e-commerce revolution it is nothing but
water with the supply-chain okay I've
become a little more specific in America
factory system automation robotics smart
devices recycling the applications go on
and on and from a from F purely the
research point of view the applications
and robotics are very exciting to us the
MIT Auto ID center our Charter is quite
simple we are developing electromagnetic
identification and sensor technology we
are also developing and that is why we
have the likes of sunny in our group and
this is truly a serendipitous event that
a mechanical engineer and a computer
scientist and a third partner who was a
roboticist happened to be in the same
department and the idea kind of came
together the one of the key things is
building a network infrastructure our
vision is and we can say that because
it's easy for us to paint a vision very
new University so I'll say it is to
carpet factories shops retail warehouses
distribution centers with readers put
them on networks ok in the hope that one
day every object will have a radio
frequency tag on it ok and the idea then
is that if you so wanted you could track
objects anywhere and once you can do
that we hope there any system where
material is being moved can be
controlled very tightly resulting very
high performance material movement and
very good supply chain management the
other goal of our of our Center is to
actually develop and propose some of the
standards just to the uniforms Code
Council standardize the bar code we are
trying to develop and propose network
standards the standards for storing the
numbers on the chips the standards for
the air Reader interface standards for
how to store the information in XML
folks book about XML and we're actually
it's kind of a new thing for university
to really do this we are reading in
hoping to understand this a little more
but forming standards is one of our key
key goals and finally to develop
applications is the most exciting thing
we're trying to develop applications for
this I mean some of the applications are
fairly obvious are those hopefully will
emerge
our sponsors are the Uniform Code
Council Procter & Gamble Gillette we
have a representative John Sunland from
International Paper Shep which is a
major logistics company they move
pallets around the world it's their
multi-million dollar company and about
six or seven more companies which are
coming on board in the next two weeks
our vision is that all physical items
that at some point have these
electromagnetic identification tags we
will have large networks of readers and
sensors and eventually we will have be
able to achieve large system monitoring
and control first-step architecture this
we have have proposed in the last four
months of the life of the center the
architecture of our that we have
proposed is as follows readers are
ubiquitous wherever we need them to be
you have readers the readers are
networked we're developing standards for
example new protocols for lightweight
protocols for for connecting these
readers tcp/ip is a very heavy protocol
there are new protocols that are lighter
so that they can work much more
efficiently for readers so now we
imagine that this room is full of
readers the readers now are gateway to
the internet for example or some network
okay on the internet you have databases
available to you which have all the
information about the objects you're
likely to see so for example if you go
to a warehouse all the objects have tags
and the warehouse is carpeted of readers
the readers can reach that they read the
tags but if you need information about a
particular tag can go down the internet
and yanked on information from a global
database about that particular object
and finally all the data is available to
the people doing the control of whatever
system it is that is being controlled
the supply chain a robot whatever now I
should also stress that to us remember
that ID is just a sixth sense the other
five sensors can as equally can equally
be integrated into our system so any
sensor in fact can fit into the system
and ID is just a sixth sense of
identification but a temperature stamp a
time stamp that humidity are all parts
of the same XML file that we can take
snapshots off when required and these
XML files are available globally on the
internet barring you know security and
privacy concerns which I'll talk about
in a second
services in place well we're soon going
to announce something we call the
electronic product code you need an e in
front of anything today to make it
useful the its it's a play on the
uniform product code UPC the electronic
product code uniform product code by the
way contains certain information about
the object but we are pure ID only ID
and the electronic product code is an ID
the object naming service if you're
familiar with the domain naming service
it is similar an object naming service
is something which will take the
gibberish which is the identification of
the object but serial number and convert
it to the URL of the website or a
database site from which you can yang
down all the information you want about
that particular object and finally it's
something called the physical markup
language which is a large XML a file
which contains all the relevant
information about the object it could be
anything from instructions for use code
for how to run the object down to you
know let's say if it's a food package
nutrition information this is stored in
a standard format on a database
somewhere I'll tell you quickly about
the three services the unique object
object identification just to give you
an idea there are about 20 million
manufacturers we are guessing today and
if you look at the number of bits
required for things like automobiles
down to grains of rice could rice you're
down to 54 bits to number every grain of
rice produced per annum so we have
plenty of bits and based on that we've
come up with a proposal for the next
generation electronic product code which
looks something like this what we're
thinking is that out of let's say we are
assuming 96 bits to begin with say about
2 bits sorry
8 bits which is 2 hex bits as a header
version the version number 24 bits for
the manufacturer 24 bits for the
particular product and about 40 bits for
the serial number of the particular item
and these numbers eventually if this
proposal is accepted will be handled by
an organization or Uniform Code Council
and and given to manufacturers so they
can buy them bid for them and then print
out chips the object naming service is
this thing which takes this gibberish
which is the EPC code and converts it to
a URL an IP address so they say and
that's what we have here the object
naming service is up and running
it's object ID dotnet the wwas
misleading is not really a website it's
just a service for a particular protocol
and you can go there and give it one of
the EPC codes it's a prototype service
right now and return a file which
contains all the information about the
day about the particular object the
physical markup language contains
temporal object data static object
information sent to sensor telemetry so
for example if you want to track the
temperatures a certain product or a
certain object has been through all
these snapshots are being stored in that
file it could be a distributed file it
could be a local file but all the
information is available control
instructions for example you might have
a state machine model of the particular
device that that is being represented so
that you can you can simulate it you can
control it compiler so you can compile
for example code to a specific machine
and finally modeling and simulation the
challenges we have obviously a lot of
challenges there's a fairly ambitious
project at the very basic level we're
working at the looking at the
electromagnetics of the tags and the
readers be for example trying to come up
with the the physics to maximize the
range at which the tags can be read
another problem is one of anti-collision
what if multiple tags respond at the
same time they could jumble each other
signal and this is a standard problem in
in networking Sonny has come up with an
algorithm for multiple for a very nice
linear algorithm for resolving
collisions in tags for example reserving
the tasks and will involve include
resolving multiple simultaneous
responses doing so a minimum time in
doing so with minimum onboard computing
because if the anti collusion algorithm
becomes complicated the chip becomes
more expensive and that kills the whole
process we record in a chicken or the
egg problem here because if the tags are
expensive there won't be manufactured in
bulk and if the are manufactured in bulk
they will remain expensive and we're
trying to break that loop eventually we
hope if we can break the loop and if
these standards take hold that barcodes
will be I wouldn't say replace but
certainly augmented with these
radiofrequency tanks another problem is
device packaging we are now talking
about placing chips on paper
okay now the particular target I'm
passing around the Motorola by statics
tag has an advantage in that the antenna
needn't be a copper wire
it could be just printed graphite
because it's an electrostatic as opposed
to any electromagnetic tag so the lot of
questions arise how do you print
graphite onto paper how do you place the
chip on the tip on the on the on the
antenna so that you get good contact and
reliable contact and how do you do it
accurately so these are some of the
problems we're dealing with and
struggling with there are also other
questions like shielding if there's
metal nearby the feel of the tag may be
interfered with and this is another
thing we need to worry about so there's
a whole plethora of problems that we're
slowly wading into but these are all
solvable problems we're quite confident
at the network level there are several
challenges the system must scale now we
talked about millions of computers today
but we're also talking in this case of
trillions perhaps hundreds of trillions
of Tanks okay so yeah this is quite a
different ballgame than even the
Internet and Sony will run out of
internet addresses so there's ipv6 which
is the new standard which we already
talked about the interesting thing is
that if you look at the internet and
Sony's book about these people are
talking about broadband and high
bandwidth and the reason is they want to
download multimedia streaming video over
the Internet this is a very different
traffic pattern what happens here is you
have thousands of very low length
messages as opposed to single very high
length messages so the congestion issues
are very different and there's a lot of
research being done in Sony's group now
we're just beginning to understand some
of these issues for for tags of course
there's the whole problem of security
and privacy initially we will avoid the
problem by only perhaps and also from a
cost perspective deploying these in in
high-value items where cost and privacy
aren't an issue for example in the
factory or inside a supply chain but
eventually when these tags get into low
value cheap items then you have to worry
about consumer privacy and security and
there are ways to deal with these
problems but again it's a matter of
planning it properly quality of service
which is making sure that for example
even you want to read a tag and you want
to get information about it if the if
the network is down you can't get
information that tag is useless because
just ID so
start thinking about those issues here
as well and finally flexibility the
Internet itself is changing but the good
news is that we are right again
it's horrendous that that a group of us
could get together with expertise in
different areas the funny canned
advisors on the on the viability of ipv6
and fourth generation wireless
technologies because he's an integral
part of that system modeling
verification and stability we're
building a huge system we have to be
aware that things might happen that we
don't we can't predict and it is
important for us to start building
models to understand these items but
understand these possible events David
broke one of our colleagues was involved
in the creation of Simba of of the of
the nationwide Pentagon a military
simulation software where you can
actually plug in different modules and
simulate sort of behavior you get we
haven't really started doing research in
this but we have to start thinking about
it
develop the modeling and simulation
tools to understand the complex dynamic
behavior of these billions of
interconnected objects this is more in
the lines of something the system's
division here would do but certainly
we've throw up a lot of problems for
them and of course there are also simple
things like for example if you download
instructions to a certain machine how do
you verify that these instructions can
be carried by the machine what do you do
if for example in fact we have a demo
you know these smart device demos are
very popular with students one of my
students hacked into a microwave and hit
the microwave now has a reader in it
and he takes food packets and places
them inside the microwave the microwave
reads the food packet figures are the ID
in about half a second goes and gets all
the cooking instructions compiles them
for the particular microwave and cooks
them the question now is how do we make
sure that the instructions that he's
downloaded are compatible to that
microwave for example a malicious
instruction might blow up the microwave
so how do you verify that so it comes
down to actually verification what our
own computer senses verification which
is modeling the microwave the finite
state machine taking instructions and
verifying it it's a form of control and
reach ability and finally looking at
issues like stability let me just cut to
the chase because I can see set standing
there looking at me
they just to give you an idea of some of
the issues that that the areas where
this can be useful this complicated
picture is actually a simple simulation
of a supply chain okay it is a it is a a
game that was invented by at MIT called
the beer game and what they do is they
actually simulate the supply chain of
beer and there's a reason for that
because the beer distribution supply
chain has very slow information
propagation and the way information is
propagated today is that that you have
the retailer the wholesaler the
distributor and the factory and when you
place an order the information week by
week goes up and then the material comes
down so there's an eight week delay
before you actually get in forget the
product now in any control system in any
dynamic system delay of course is is a
bugbear so what happens is that when you
play this game but you have students sit
at a table and order this we show them
how unpredictable the dynamics of the
system can be this was developed by the
system dynamics group at MIT we can also
play the game where you simulate for
example and this is done on a computer
the the rapid flow of information you
say that let's say that if there are
tags in the warehouses and information
is freely available okay what happens is
that if you can do this and you run the
two simulations it's kind of interesting
to see the sort of results you get with
our information flow this is the sort of
supply chain performance you get you get
very cyclical supply chain performance
they stock out there's overstock okay
with this information you get fairly
steady and this is just a simple demo
that a simple simulation that that we
were doing to understand this you get
much more predictable behavior the
supply chain it's much more constant
okay and we talk we heard Alex talk
about earlier and Popkin de toros and
talked about earlier but how fast the
supply chain needs to work today in
order to keep up with the rapid
obsolescence of products and what
happens with this is that you can now
start pulling your safety stocks down
bring down the level of safety stocks so
that it's a pledge is much more
efficient because you have instant
information of when the station down the
line has run out of material there's a
buzzword for it which is you know pull
and
falls into the that level but at a more
at the most general level what we are
concentrating on is standards the
infrastructure the technology the pure
engineering of making these systems work
and someone else will hopefully come in
and use these technologies to improve
the performance of Industry conclusions
we this is really a system level
engineering solution we have a computer
scientist a mechanical engineer about us
is working on this and other other
faculty members in our department who
can give us expertise on this for
example XML we have folks here Oban
we're using XML for the last three or
four years we have a blend of
information technology and mechanical
engineering system dynamics it's really
a new role for university because
standards and infrastructure development
you know it's usually done outside of
universities but we're taking the plunge
hoping that we can make an impact the
bad news is that this can't be done by a
company because everyone's trying to own
the whole pie it's gotta be done at a at
a you know in Geneva you know
non-aligned location and MIT we hope is
is the right place you can get more
information at HTTP colon or to ID'd or
mit.edu thanks a lot
[Applause]
destroying the IDs
yeah there are two ways to approach the
problem the first is ESM and we have
been thinking about recycling the ID so
for example when it goes into the trash
for certain items you can you know free
that ID certain be reused but the other
way to look at is look at it is right
now we have 120 in bits when you go to
256 we can really be almost wasteful
with the numbers and get away with it
you know after 100 years you start
reusing the numbers so the answer to
your question is yes we've thought about
it a little bit and we're not too
worried
we think about jism retires and so forth
what's camp and get down to before that
becomes a problem like the manufacturing
or something made of thousand pieces can
you track where almost out pieces are
actually from the robotics point of view
that George and I have been talking
about this for some time and Sonny and
I've been talking about this to some
extent you know for example a cell phone
is a localization scheme I mean if I
know which cell you're in from your cell
phone but it's a very large localization
scheme but in this the cells are about a
foot by foot so within a foot you can
get it the question is can you get it
down to within a few millimeters and can
you get orientation that's not there's
no obvious way to do that yet and the
reason is it's just a field you can't
really do any tomography and kind of
reconstruct but there's other things you
can do for example you can scan space
and try and pick up location so we have
really looked into that much we've just
talked about it you know eventually I
think that'll be very useful
[Music]
it's very exciting yeah obviously be
very very careful about that for one
thing that you know the before these
things get into your home it's um it's
many many years that's that's the one
thing to say this is usually the min
right now it's for palettes and
factories that's how you're going to
start but that's a very pertinent
question and the answer is that the
number by itself is useless okay it's
when you can go to the object naming
service and get information that it
becomes useful otherwise the numbers you
can even in fact intentionally randomize
the numbers so you no one has any idea
what what it is and if we can control
the object naming service we can for
example the moment an object is checked
out lose the number so we never know
what the number is again that's one
thing the other thing is that we're also
working on ways in which you can
scramble the number of you wanted if you
really wanted to keep the ID you could
physically destroy it if you wanted
and finally the range is very small okay
the range is only a few feet but that
doesn't make it foolproof but that also
helps but yes that's something very
concerned about in something we continue
to look at
[Music]
we are contemplating a standards-based
protocol but I'll let Sonny handle that
one
sorry we have known a protocol which is
very lightweight and we want to achieve
the necessary to morning misters so they
will use our MIT standard are you
familiar with line works there's a
relatively recent ANSI standard on a
lightweight protocol for my company
hello in works but right now the is
owned by the company no it's public
domain in the sense that there's two
chip suppliers and providing line work
chips
in Cyprus so we want to make the proof
was really very lightly the question I
think service you mean to say that each
tag would go to a specific or separate
it's up to the functionality that you
want them and if you want to take a
stock keeping unit and give it you know
for example if all coke cans made in may
have only one site that's up to cook but
if for some reason you want to track you
know for example in Belgium there was
this care but some coke cans going bad
if you wanted to do that maybe you could
do things like based on the level of
information you want you redirect it to
a particular very tiny web database
location where information particular to
that instance was located but that's it
doesn't evolve but we certainly want to
keep that an available option
exactly
it's a very good question UPC is only 13
digits so it's not really enough UPC is
really meant to identify every
particular what they call an SKU stock
keeping unit so for example all cokes
would be the same as it turns out we can
actually embed and we do embed the UPC
code in this so theoretically you could
do that
in fact because they have 128 bits one
of I think a few fields are just UPC
right now pure your PC
[Applause]